You know what, I'm going to make you put both versions in the show notes, and we're going to see what the listener thinks, because the listener's going to be on my side. The listener's uninformed as well. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 56 56 recorded on December 5th, 2021. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we live code a BQN solution to a leak code problem. This is part two of a two-part episode. I recommend checking out the first episode before listening to this one. so before we hop into part two of this two-part episode i am going to briefly cover the problem description that we're going to be solving so basically it's a toy problem you're given two
你知道吗，我要让你把两个版本都写进节目简介里，然后我们看看听众怎么想，因为听众会站在我这边。听众也是不知情的。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客，第 56 集，录制于 2021 年 12 月 5 日。我是康纳，今天我的联合主持人是布赖斯，我们在现场用 BQN 编写一个 LeetCode 问题的解决方案。这是两集节目的第二部分。建议在听这一集之前先去听听第一部分。所以在我们进入这两集节目的第二部分之前，我将简要介绍一下我们要解决的问题描述，基本上这是一个玩具问题，给你两个
inputs a list of numbers and a target value in the form of a single number. And basically what you are asked to return is the indices that the target value would show up if you were to sort the list of numbers that you're given. So for instance, if the list of numbers you're given is 20, 30, 10, and your target value is 20, after you sort that list of numbers, it's going to be 10 20 30 and then the index that the 20 your target value shows up is 1 and if there were multiple 20s so if it was 20 20 30 10 then instead of returning just a single one you'll be returning index 1 and 2 because the 20s would be in the middle indices hope that makes sense now let's hop into the episode. And now let's go and do something similar in BQM. So let's hop over to our next gen APL.
输入：一个数字列表和一个单个数字形式的目标值。基本上要求你返回的是，如果你把给定的数字列表排序后，目标值将会出现的位置索引。举个例子，如果你给定的数字列表是 20、30、10，而你的目标值是 20，在你对该数字列表排序后，它会变成 10、20、30，然后 20（你的目标值）出现的索引是 1。如果有多个 20，比如它是 20、20、30、10，那么你返回的就不仅仅是一个单一的数字，而是索引 1 和 2，因为 20 会在中间的索引位置。希望这很好理解，现在让我们进入本集节目。现在让我们去 BQN 中做类似的事情。所以让我们跳到我们的下一代 APL。
Wait, wait, wait. Finally an APL for your flying saucer? Yeah, that's Marshall Lockbaum's, like, you know, wants it to run everywhere kind of thing. So I think it's a bad motto, but hey. If you're listening, Marshall, don't at me. So first thing we're going to do. You can't at him and you can't at me because it is a bad motto.
等等，等等，等等。终于有一款适合你飞碟的 APL 了？对，那是马歇尔·洛克鲍姆（Marshall Lockbaum）那种，你知道的，希望它能在任何地方运行的那种东西。所以我认为这是一个糟糕的座右铭，但是嘿。如果你在听的话，马歇尔，别艾特我。所以我们要做的第一件事。你不能艾特他，你也不能艾特我，因为它确实是一个糟糕的座右铭。
You should change it. The first thing we do here, we've got our 1, 2, 5, 3, 2 array, and we're going to sort it, which is a single character. We've got to zoom out here a little bit so you can see the result., we've got our 1, 2, 5, 3, 2 array, and we're gonna sort it, which is a single character. We gotta zoom out here a little bit so you can see the result. Now we've sorted. Now in order to get our sort of elements that are equal to our target,
你应该改掉它。我们在这里做的第一件事，我们有我们的 1、2、5、3、2 数组，我们要对它进行排序，这是一个单字符。我们得在这里缩小一点画面，这样你就能看到结果了。我们有我们的 1、2、5、3、2 数组，我们要对它进行排序，这是一个单字符。我们得在这里缩小一点画面，这样你就能看到结果了。现在我们排序完了。现在为了得到与我们目标相等的已排序元素，
we just, here our target value is two, and we go equal, and boom, you have a Boolean mask that represents where you had the target value. So the result right now is 0, 1, 1, 0, 0. And there happens to be an algorithm or a glyph in BQN and also J and APL. It's called where in BQN and APL. It's called indices in J. And it's a slash. And if you do this, it just returns you the indices that correspond to those ones. So that is like three characters on top of the two arguments that are sort of in line here,
我们只需，这里我们的目标值是 2，然后我们输入等于，砰，你就得到了一个布尔掩码，它表示你有目标值的位置。所以现在的结果是 0、1、1、0、0。在 BQN 以及 J 和 APL 中碰巧有一个算法或一个符号。它在 BQN 和 APL 中被称为 where。它在 J 中被称为 indices。它是一个斜杠。如果你这样做，它就会返回与这些 1 相对应的索引。所以这就像是在两个内联的参数之上加上了三个字符，
but let's make this point three. So what's the name of this? It's target indices. So let's call this target indices arrow. And we're going to call this by doing target indices and then copying this over. So we can just turn this into like an inline lambda. Why is there the two there? So that's, it's a binary function.
但让我们把这个命名为 point three。所以这个叫什么名字？它是 target indices。所以我们把这个叫做 target indices 箭头。我们要通过执行 target indices 然后把这个复制过来来调用它。所以我们可以把它变成一个内联的 lambda。为什么这里有个 2？所以那是，它是一个二元函数。
So there's two arguments and binary functions are infix in apls like bqn wait what are the two arguments so two is the left argument and but why is it taking two as an argument i'm confused oh that's the target value oh okay yeah um less confused now thank you and so we can replace our left argument here, which is W, and right argument, which is X. And so this should give us 1, 2. Wait, what happened with W? So W is our left argument. X is our right argument.
所以有两个参数，二元函数在像 bqn 这样的 apl 中是中缀的。等等，哪两个参数？所以 2 是左参数，但是为什么它把 2 作为参数呢？我很困惑。哦，那是目标值。哦，好吧，嗯，不那么困惑了，谢谢。所以我们可以用这里的左参数（即 W）和右参数（即 X）来替换。所以这应该给我们 1、2。等等，W 怎么了？所以 W 是我们的左参数。X 是我们的右参数。
In APL, it's alpha and omega. But we're going to change this to point-free because... Shouldn't... Yeah, okay. All right, all right. I i'm gonna shut up for a minute and let you do your thing and so what we have here is you know a unary operation being applied to our list which is sort and then a binary function that's taking the result of that sorted list and checking whether any of those elements are equal to our target value and
在 APL 中，它们是 alpha 和 omega。但我们要把它改成无点（point-free）形式，因为……不应该……好吧，好吧，好吧。我，我闭嘴一分钟，让你做你自己的事。所以我们这里有的是，你知道的，一个作用于我们列表的一元操作，也就是排序，然后是一个二元函数，它获取该排序列表的结果，并检查这些元素中的任何一个是否等于我们的目标值，以及
So we can turn this to point free by doing the following we're going to turn this into a fork and Basically This is going to be taking the target value on the left so it's saying take the target value on the left. So it's saying take the target value on the left. And then we're going to do the same thing over here and say, take the one on the right, but we want to compose these together and say, basically after you do this binary function,
所以我们可以通过以下方式将其转换为无点形式：我们将把它变成一个叉子（fork），基本上这将把目标值放在左边，所以它说把目标值放在左边。所以它说把目标值放在左边。然后我们要在右边做同样的事情，说，拿右边的那个，但我们要把它们组合在一起，说，基本上在你做了这个二元函数之后，
apply this unary function. So this is the B one combinator at the Blackbird altogether. You've lost me at some point here. So remember that we have done in the past our forks, which are A, B, and C. So currently, A on the left is our left, meaning given two arguments here, take the left one.
应用这个一元函数。所以这是黑鸟组合子中的 B1 组合子。你在这里把我给说糊涂了。所以记住我们过去做过我们的叉子，也就是 A、B 和 C。所以目前，左边的 A 是我们的左边，意味着在这里给定两个参数时，取左边的一个。
And then equal is our binary function, and on the right is a composition of sort plus right. So first we want to say only take our right argument, and then we want to sort it. And because this is a binary operation, takes two arguments, and then discards the left one, and this is a unary operation. This is an example of the B1 combinator. And then when you compose these things in parentheses, that gives you the golden eagle, a specialization of the EHAP combinator.
然后等于号是我们的二元函数，右边是排序加右边的组合。所以首先我们只想取我们的右参数，然后我们想对它进行排序。而且因为这是一个二元操作，它接受两个参数，然后丢弃左边的一个，而这是一个一元操作。这是 B1 组合子的一個例子。然后当你在括号中组合这些东西时，这就成了金雕，是 EHAP 组合子的一个特化。
And what's awesome is that without any parentheses, or without, like there's two different ways to spell the b1 combinator you can spell it by using this sort of symbol or just by juxtaposing like putting side by side a unary and a binary function and this is a unary function and our specialization of the ehat combinator is a binary function so when you just this is the equivalent of this, just because there's nothing else going on. Wait, why isn't that true for the sort in the right side? Because it's going to eagerly try and make a fork out of this, either a unary or dyadic one. So we need to compose this to say this is a unary function.
最棒的是，在没有任何括号的情况下，或者在，就像拼写 b1 组合子有两种不同的方式，你可以通过使用这种符号来拼写它，或者仅仅通过并置——把一个一元函数和一个二元函数放在一起——而这是一个一元函数，而我们 ehat 组合子的特化是一个二元函数，所以当你只，这相当于这个，仅仅是因为没有其他事情发生。等等，为什么右边的排序不适用这一点？因为它会急切地试图从中做一个叉子，要么是一元的，要么是双元的。所以我们需要组合它来表明这是一个一元函数。
So the composition has a stronger operator precedence? Correct. Yes. Dude, just use parentheses. What have parentheses done to hurt you? And we can delete the only remaining two parentheses because this
所以组合具有更强的运算符优先级？正确。是的。老兄，直接用括号不就行了。括号对你做什么了，让你这么痛恨？我们可以删掉仅剩的两个括号，因为这个
forms a fork which is a binary operation. And this is a unary operation. So implicitly, this is the B1 combinator. Connor. Boom. Come on. Come on.
构成了叉子，这是一个二元操作。而这是一个一元操作。所以隐式地，这就是 B1 组合子。康纳。砰。来吧。来吧。
Connor, this is strictly less readable than what you had before. I disagree. I disagree. It is beautiful. rules of precedence for the specific operators in this specific language for how you construct this and not like you're assuming that everybody's going to read and understand all of those precedence rules and be able to apply them on the spot to be able to disentangle what this is doing like like if you if if if you use the parentheses here even if I don't know what the specific operations are, I at least would understand the structure of the problem. But that's because you know how parentheses evaluate.
康纳，这绝对比你之前写的更难读。我不同意。我不同意。它很美。特定语言中特定运算符的优先级规则，决定了你如何构建这个东西，而不是像你假设的那样，每个人都会阅读并理解所有这些优先级规则，并能够当场应用它们来解开这行代码在做什么——就像如果你，如果你，如果你在这里使用括号，即使我不知道具体的操作是什么，我至少能理解问题的结构。但那是因为你知道括号是如何求值的。
Like the readability of this is informed by your understanding of how parentheses are evaluated. But I only have to understand how one thing evaluates, parentheses. For your form of this, one has to understand how all of these things evaluate and which of these things are binary and unary. I mean the argument you're making here is like, okay, why do we have multiplication? Let's just use addition for everything because then I only have to know one binary operator plus and I can I can still do I can still do exponents and I can still do multiplication by just repeatedly adding it's it's the same argument it's the same argument no no you're saying that like oh parentheses is one thing here I need to know the b1 combinator the two different ways of spelling it the uh the s or it's not an s prime combinator it's a specialization of the e-hat combinator like i have to know all that stuff um and it's like yeah you know i'm gonna make you put both
就像这段代码的可读性，是建立在你对括号如何求值 理解的基础上的。但我只需要理解一件事是如何求值的，那就是括号。对于你这种形式，一个人必须理解所有这些东西是如何求值的，以及其中哪些是二元和一元的。我的意思是，你在这里提出的论据就像是，好吧，为什么我们要有乘法？让我们对所有东西都只用加法，因为这样我只需要知道一个二元运算符加号，我就可以，我仍然可以做指数运算，我仍然可以通过重复相加来做乘法，这，这是同样的论据，这是同样的论据。不，不，你是说，哦，括号是一回事，这里我需要知道 b1 组合子、拼写它的两种不同方式、呃，s 或者它不是 s 素数组合子，它是 e-hat 组合子的一个特化——就像我必须知道所有这些东西一样，这就像是，是的，你知道，我要让你把这两个
versions on um in the show notes and we're gonna see what the listener thinks because the listener's gonna be on my listeners uninformed as well uh connor do you want this podcast to be successful if so might i suggest that you not insult the dear listener it's like asking someone that doesn't speak chinese or like no you know any of the radicals it's like oh what do you what do you think about the readability of this of this uh and it's like oh well one of the solutions makes use of something that's in the individual's lexicon they know what parentheses are so they can identify those and go oh i know some of that structure but like that's only because they know that's like it's you know i was just having this conversation with a uh prophet one of the local universities about, you know, small talk versus APL and that APL is very opaque. But like, the point that I made to him is that like, the opacity of a language,
版本放在，呃，节目简介里，我们看看听众怎么想，因为听众会站在我这，听众也是不知情的，呃，康纳，你希望这个播客成功吗？如果是的话，我可不可以建议你不要侮辱亲爱的听众？这就像问一个不会说中文或者，或者不认识任何偏旁部首的人，就像，哦，你觉得这个，这段代码的可读性怎么样？就像，哦，好吧，其中一个解决方案利用了个人词汇表中的东西，他们知道括号是什么，所以他们可以识别这些并说，哦，我知道一些那样的结构，但这只是因为他们知道，这就像是，你知道的，我刚刚在跟一位，呃，本地大学的教授谈论，你知道的，Smalltalk 与 APL 相比，A-P-L 是非常不透明的。但是，呃，我向他提出的观点是，语言的不透明性，
like, and he said that small talk is so much readable, but that's because small talk is so much more similar to English, the language that like everyone knows, just because something is different than the language that you speak, doesn't't like doesn't necessitate that it's actually more opaque like we know what parentheses do therefore this one seems more familiar and it's like well that's like the difference between showing a paragraph of chinese symbols versus a paragraph of chinese symbols with some english words littered in and you you ask which one is is can you make more sense of and it's like well of course the one that has more english words in that you know is is more readable i i i fantastic point the point that you're trying to make i think you are completely wrong and i think i think that when we take this to twitter people are gonna agree with me uh i mean and i i agree you will win on twitter
比如，他说 Smalltalk 容易读得多，但那是因为 Smalltalk 与英语——每个人都懂的语言——相似得多，仅仅因为某种东西不同于你所说的语言，并不意味着它实际上更不透明。我们知道括号的作用，因此这个看起来更熟悉，这就像展示一段中文字符与展示一段夹杂着一些英文字母的中文字符之间的区别，你问哪一个更能让人理解，就像，当然是那个包含更多你认识的英语单词的那个，可读性更好。我，我，这是一个绝妙的观点，你试图表达的观点，我认为你完全错了，我认为，我认为当我们把这个拿到推特上去时，人们会同意我的观点。呃，我的意思是，我同意你会在推特上获胜，
but that doesn't mean that you're right. That is a fair enough point. All right. Now let's see how we would solve this the efficient way. Oh, yeah, yeah. So that's, I, it's pretty fun. It's pretty fun. So let's, let's comment out this for now. And yeah, let's just, let's build it up in lines again.
但这并不意味着你是对的。这倒是个挺公道的观点。好了。现在让我们看看如何用高效的方法来解决这个问题。哦，对，对。所以那是，我，这挺好玩的。挺好玩的。所以让我们，我们先把这个注释掉。然后，是的，让我们，让我们再一行一行地把它构建起来。
So the first thing we want to do is check how many elements are less than our target. And we do that with just two less than our list. And to get equal, we just do two equal list. So how do we do those at the same time? Does that give you the count of elements or does that give you? It just gives you a mask. So all you have to do is a plus reduction. Yeah, I was about to say a reduction.
所以我们要做的第一件事是检查有多少元素小于我们的目标。我们只需用 2 小于我们的列表就能做到这一点。要得到等于，我们只需做 2 等于列表。那么我们如何同时做到这两点呢？这给你的元素的计数还是给你？它只给一个掩码。所以你只需要做一个加法归约。对，我正要说归约。
We need to do composition here. Or not actually composition, it's partial application. We're binding two to the equal sign and the less than sign. So for equal, we get two. two and for less than we get one hang on explain explain what you just did uh so this little circle with the line coming out of it is called i think before but it basically just means like partial application you're binding two as the left argument to your binary operation, either equal or... It's turning that into a unary operation. Yep. And so now that we have two unary operations composed
我们需要在这里进行组合。或者其实不是组合，是偏应用。我们将 2 绑定到等于号和小于号上。对于等于，我们得到 2 等于，对于小于，我们得到 2 小于。等等，解释一下，解释一下你刚刚做了什么。呃，这个带有一条线的圆圈，我想之前被称为，但它基本上只意味着偏应用，你将 2 作为左参数绑定到你的二元操作上，无论是等于还是……它正在把它变成一元操作。是的。所以现在我们有了两个组合在一起或并置的
or juxtaposed, that's the B combinator. So it's the equivalent of just doing one after the other. Which is... I'm confused. You've lost me. What is the little back tick-like thing? That's reduce. The plus is not reduced? The back tick-like thing is reduced?
一元操作，这就是 B 组合子。所以这相当于一个接一个地执行。也就是……我糊涂了。你把我搞糊涂了。那个长得像反引号的东西是什么？那是归约。加号不是归约吗？那个长得像反引号的东西是归约？
The plus is a binary operation, as it is in everything like mathematics. Oh, okay. I get what you're saying. It's like the equivalent of std colon colon plus parentheses parentheses that you pass to std reduce. std reduce is a algorithm that takes a binary operation. Yes, I now see what this does. Okay, let's move on. So once you have this, you can basically, let's just catenate them for now. And we can just basically copy and paste this. And instead of this, we want equals. And then we can turn this all into a fork. And so now we have the count of values
加号是一个二元操作，就像在数学等所有东西中一样。哦，好吧。我明白你的意思了。这就像传递给 std reduce 的 std 冒号冒号加号括号括号的等价物。std reduce 是一个接受二元操作的算法。是的，我现在明白这是做什么的了。好吧，我们继续。一旦你有了这个，你基本上可以，我们现在先把它们拼接（catenate）起来。然后我们基本上可以复制并粘贴这个。不用这个，我们要等于。然后我们可以把这一切都变成一个叉子。所以现在我们有了值的计数，
that are less than our target and the count of values that are equal to our target and once okay wait what okay you have those two cat counts but then what what what is the concatenate catenates just putting them next to each other so this is this evaluates to one okay all right and this evaluates to two right but the this is perhaps a bad input example because... Oh yeah, sure. Yeah, because the correct result is also, is the same as... The first two elements. Yeah. Or the correct elements for it to return are,
它们小于我们的目标，以及等于我们目标的值的计数，一旦，哦，等等，什么？哦，你有那两个拼接计数，但随后，什么，什么，什么事拼接？拼接只是把它们放在一起，所以这个求值为 1，好吧，好的，这个求值为 2，对吧？但这个可能是一个糟糕的输入例子，因为……哦，对，当然。是的，因为正确的结果也是，和……前两个元素相同。是的。或者它要返回的正确元素是，
I don't know what I'm saying. So yeah, I just multiplied all the elements in the target value by 10. So now we have 10, 20, 50, 30, 20. And the result is that you get- No, no, no, but hang on. That doesn't change anything because the correct output indices are one and two.
我不知道我在说什么。所以，是的，我把目标值中的所有元素都乘以了 10。所以现在我们有 10、20、50、30、20。结果是你得到了——不，不，不，但是等等。这不会改变任何事情，因为正确的输出索引是 1 和 2。
Oh yeah, yeah, sure. Let's do- And the answer to how many elements are less than the target is one and how many elements are equal to the target is two. So you'd have to change the order. Or just add a bunch more 20. So now I have 10, 20, 50, 30, 20, 20, 20.
哦，对，对，当然。让我们做——那么有多少元素小于目标的答案是 1，有多少元素等于目标的答案是 2。所以你得改变顺序。或者只是再加一堆 20。所以现在我有 10、20、50、30、20、20、20。
So you've got four elements that are equal to 20. I am satisfied. One that's less. And so what we can do now is we can just add iota, which looks different and it's called range in BQM. And I think this, actually, this isn't going to work, so we need to do this. And so now we've got one still evaluating as our left, and then we've got iota, which is zero index, so it's one two three and then all we have to do is replace our catnate with plus and now you're adding one to every single one of the iota values so you're going
所以你有四个元素等于 20。我很满意。有一个小于。所以我们现在可以做的是，我们可以只加上 iota，它看起来不同，在 BQN 中被称为范围（range）。而且我认为这个，实际上，这行不通，所以我们需要这样做。所以现在我们有 1 仍然作为我们的左边，然后我们有 iota，它是从 0 开始索引的，所以它是 1、2、3，然后我们要做的全部就是用加号替换我们的拼接，现在你正在给每一个 iota 值加 1，所以你会
to end up with one two three four boom that's crazy um and and this is like hang on hang on let me process let me process yeah okay i guess that works that's clever now can you lift out the oh let's go there let's go there. Let's go there, man. I love where your head's at. I love where your head's at. So yeah, Bryce is basically asking, because we've got a lot of commonality here.
最终得到 1、2、3、4，砰，这太疯狂了。嗯，而且，这就像，等等，等等，让我消化一下，让我消化一下。好吧，我想这行得通，这很聪明。现在，你能把这个提取出来吗？哦，我们去那吧，我们去那吧。我们去那吧，老兄。我喜欢你的思路。我喜欢你的思路。所以，是的，布赖斯基本上在问，因为我们这里有很多共同点。
Basically, the plus reduce, and then basically binding the target value to our binary operation. The only thing that's different between those two is one's using a less than or a greater than, a less than, I guess, and one of them is using an equal. So let's see if we can do that.
基本上，加法归约，然后基本上将目标值绑定到我们的二元操作。这两者之间唯一的区别是一个使用的是小于或大于，一个小于，我想，其中一个使用的是等于。所以让我们看看我们能不能做到这一点。
Let's go to, and actually, so we're not actually, wait, the first thing we should do is pass 20 in here because we have a unary function where we have the 20 hard-coded. That's not good. And so... You're trying to keep it point-free, aren't you? Wait, does this actually work?
让我们去，实际上，所以我们不是，等等，我们应该做的第一件事是把 20 传进来，因为我们有一个硬编码了 20 的一元函数。那可不好。所以……你正试图保持无点风格，不是吗？等等，这真的行得通吗？
I never did this before. Oh my god! That is so beautiful. Oh my god. Can I get rid of the parentheses here now, too? He's just a madman, people. Wow. That is so beautiful.
我以前从没这么做过。哦，天哪！太美了。哦，天哪。现在我也可以把这里的括号去掉吗？人们啊，他简直是个疯子。哇。太美了。
Can we get rid of the parentheses? We cannot. And why does that not work? Because, yeah, we need this whole thing to evaluate as a single operation. So what we have now here is parentheses plus reduce greater than, end parentheses, plus parentheses range dot plus reduce equals. You know what the scariest thing is? The scariest thing is that that actually kind of makes sense to me.
我们能去掉括号吗？我们不能。为什么那样行不通？因为，是的，我们需要整个这段代码作为单个操作求值。所以我们现在这里有的是：括号加归约大于，右括号，加括号范围点加归约等于。你知道最可怕的事情是什么吗？最可怕的事情是这对我来说居然有点说得通。
And let's see if we can factor out. Yeah. Now, what we're trying to factor out is the plus reduce. The plus, yeah. And then some operation because we should only need to do that. So really what we're doing is we want the left and right binary functions on our dyadic fork to just be greater than and equals. So we want the greater than to be on the left and the equals to be on the right. And then we're going to use something called the psi combinator, which basically takes two arguments, pre-processes both of those arguments by applying a unary operation, in this case, reduction or summation. And once we've done that,
让我们看看我们是否可以把公共部分提取出来。是的。现在，我们要试图提取的是加法归约。加号，是的。然后是一些操作，因为我们只需要做那件事。所以实际上我们在做的是，我们希望我们的双元叉子上的左侧和右侧二元函数就是大于和等于。所以我们希望大于在左边，等于在右边。然后我们要使用一个叫做 psi 组合子的东西，它基本上接受两个参数，通过应用一元操作（在这个例子中是归约或求和）来预处理这两个参数。一旦我们完成了这个，
I think it's K here. What do we want to do? We want basically to call range on one of these values, which we're going to need to compose like this. And then the other one is just we're not doing anything to it. That doesn't look like that worked, did it? That did not produce the desired result. So let's see what happens when we delete this and we just use cat nation here. So we get 310.
我想这里是 K。我们想做什么？我们基本上想在其中一个值上调用范围，我们需要像这样组合它。然后另一个我们什么也不做。那看起来不像成功了，是吗？那没有产生预期的结果。所以让我们看看当我们删除这个并在此时使用拼接时会发生什么。所以我们得到 310。
How would this possibly give you the right result? You got rid of less than. No, it's over here. Oh, I missed that. Although, actually, yeah, there was an extra plus sign in there. You're right. Oh, my God. But so we did it.
这怎么可能给你正确的结果？你把小于去掉了。不，它在这儿。哦，我漏掉了。不过，事实上，是的，里面多了一个加号。你是对的。哦，天哪。但我们成功了。
We did it. No, wait. No way. That works? Yeah. What did we have before, though? Because I'm not actually sure which one. That was very nice.
我们成功了。不，等等。没门。那行得通？是的。不过我们之前有什么？因为我其实不确定到底是哪一个。那非常不错。
We have that with a plus. And then? Then, yeah, the little dot. with a plus. Yeah, plus. And then... Then, yeah, the little... The dot. Then you had a dot, too. So why is the reason that this one ends up being... Wait, wait, wait. You had a dot between the rain...
我们有一个带加号的那个。然后呢？然后，是的，小点。带加号。是的，加号。然后……然后，是的，那个小的……点。你刚才也有个点。那么为什么这个最终会变成……等等，等等。你在范围之间加了一个点……
Oh, yeah, that's right. That's right. Boom! Check out my BQN knowledge! Yeah, Bryce, you're leveling up. Wow. Isn't that phenomenal? Wait, wait, did we check that the original one works?
哦，对，没错。没错。砰！见识一下我的 BQN 知识！是的，布赖斯，你在升级。哇。这不是很惊人吗？等等，等等，我们检查过原来的那个能用吗？
Yep, they still give the same result. Oh, boy. That is phenomenal. That is phenomenal. Like, there's something, you know, say what you will about readability and, you know, practical use of this and whether people would actually, but, like, there is something, there's something just so beautiful. So,
是的，它们给出的结果还是一样的。哦，天哪。这太惊人了。这太惊人了。就像，有一点，你知道的，不管你怎么说可读性和，你知道的，这东西的实际用途以及人们是否真的会，但是，像，确实有某种，有某种东西是如此之美。所以，
so like, it's just, it's, it's exactly what is needs to be done. Nothing more, you know? So when you write the parallel version of this, you presumably don't want to do it with two actual count of passes.
所以就像，它正是，正是需要做的事情。不多不少，你知道吗？所以当你编写它的并行版本时，你大概不想用两个实际的计数遍历来做。
You just do it with one pass. Yeah. So I'm not sure how you just test you you can do both the count for equal and the count for less than in the same the same time yeah yeah i'm not exactly sure how a compiler because this is a fork well i mean i think if you look at the second version here that we have where we lifted out the um or no yeah if you look at the second version here that we have where we lifted out the, or no, yeah, if you look at the, switch the order of those two there, switch the order of those, those two definitions, because that, yes, that's the most refined version. If you look at this final,
你只需用一次遍历。是的。所以我不太确定你如何测试——你可以同时做等于的计数和小于的计数，对吧？是的，是的，我不太确定编译器如何——因为这是一个叉子，嗯，我的意思是，我想如果你看看这里的第二个版本，我们把那个提取出来了，或者不，是的，如果你看看这里的第二个版本，我们把那个提取出来了，或者不，是的，如果你看看那个，交换那两个的顺序，交换那两个的顺序，因为那个，是的，那是精炼程度最高版本。如果你看这个最终的，
most refined version, I think that it's pretty clear from that that you can figure that the compiler can figure out to do it in one pass because you only have the one reduction there. It's one reduction that's being applied to two different sequences, right? Right, right. But, well, it's two pseudo sequences. Yes, it's two pre-processed sequences. But, like, those two reductions can't be fused why not because at
精炼程度最高的版本，我认为从这一点上可以很清楚地看出，你可以发现编译器可以弄清楚如何在一单次遍历中完成它，因为你那里只有一个归约。这是一个被应用于两个不同序列的归约，对吧？对，对。但是，嗯，它是两个伪序列。是的，它是两个预处理过的序列。但是，就像，这两个归约不能被融合吗？为什么不能？因为归根结底
the end of the day they are pre-processed sequences that come from the same source sequence but the interim sequence is different right um yes but i'm pretty sure the compiler could figure out that i'm pretty sure the compiler could could figure this out and do this in a single pass. You just figure out, hey, I need to transform, you know, for each element, I need to transform it into these two different pre-processed pseudo elements and then feed it into this reduction. Yeah. I mean, I think it's pretty clear to you and I that we could write, you know, a thrust reduce that does this in a single pass. Yes. And I mean, I think it is also the case that all of the information that the compiler would
它们是来自同一个源序列的预处理序列，但中间序列是不同的大约……是的，但我很确信编译器可以弄清楚这一点，我很确信编译器可以弄清楚这一点并在单次遍历中完成它。你只需弄清楚，嘿，我需要转换，你知道的，对于每个元素，我需要把它转换成这两个不同的预处理伪元素，然后把它喂进这个归约里。是的。我的意思是，我认为你和我都很清楚，我们可以写一个，你知道的，在单次遍历中完成这个的 thrust reduce。是的。我的意思是，这也是事实，编译器为了进行该优化所需的所有信息应该也都在这里。那是真的，确实。是的。你只是从中得到一对数字。归根结底，你可以通过一个单一的归约来做到这一点，这个归约基本上是在做投影。你正在做一个修改它的一元操作。然后你对这两者都进行求和。
need to do that optimization should be here too. That is true, really. Yeah. You're just getting a pair of numbers out of this. And ultimately, you could do this in a single reduction that is doing a basically projection. You're doing a unary operation that modifies it. And then you're doing a summation for both of those.
这里也需要进行优化。确实如此。是的。你只是从这里得到了一对数字。最终，你可以通过单次约简来实现这一点，这基本上就是一次投影。你正在执行一个修改它的单目操作。然后，你对这两者进行求和。
Now we just have to go right set compiler. Yeah. Or more accurately, you have to go right set compiler and I will get popcorn watch. Yeah. Isn't this crazy though? It is crazy. It is.
现在我们只需要去写一个编译器了。是的。或者更准确地说，你必须去写一个编译器，而我将拿着爆米花看着。是的。不过这难道不疯狂吗？这确实很疯狂。确实如此。
Like it's, it's elegant. It's phenomenal. Like, um, and that's the thing is I solved this and initially was like, oh my goodness, this is one of the most beautiful, you know, BQN expressions I've seen. And then like was trying to fall asleep, was dead tired at like midnight the other night on Friday and was just like holy smokes you don't need to sort and then I like jumped out of bed went to BQN wrote these things didn't actually I have it literally uh you can here I'll show you on my other screen this is my other computer and and it actually has the exact same things. But you'll note that the twos are still – we did even better here.
就像它，它是优雅的。这太惊人了。就像，呃，就是这样，我解决了这个问题，最初觉得，哦，天哪，这是我见过最美丽的 BQN 表达式之一。然后就像试图入睡，前天周五午夜时分已经累得要命，然后就觉得，天哪，你根本不需要排序，然后我像跳下床一样冲到 BQN 前写下这些东西，其实我甚至没有——我 literalmente 有它，呃，你可以，这里我会在我的另一块屏幕上展示给你，这是我的另一台计算机，它实际上有完全相同的东西。但你会注意到 2 仍然是——我们在这里做得更好。
I want to note that right now Connor is sharing his screen with me, and I'm looking at BQN. And Connor has also taken his laptop where previously I saw his smiling face and now that is pointing at a different computer screen that also has BQN on it. So Connor is sharing two separate video streams of BQN with me right now. Yeah. Wouldn't it be crazy to, if, if this, cause really this here is, we are like, this is basically,
我想指出，现在康纳正在和我共享他的屏幕，我正看着 BQN。康纳还拿起了他的笔记本电脑，之前我看到的是他微笑的脸，而现在它正对着另一台电脑屏幕，上面也显示着 BQN。所以康纳现在正与我共享两个独立的 BQN 视频流。是的。如果这个，因为这里的实际情况是，我们就像，这基本上，
this could be a combinator that like, I think in J a dyadic hook probably does something like this, where this is like the equivalent, like where it says two juxtapositions of a binary and a unary function yeah or apply the unary to one of them to the right one and then take the left argument just as is and then apply the binary operation like this would be possible although in j they chose you know dyadic and unary hooks to mean something different than they do like hooks don't exist in apl and we use the b1 combinator and the b combinator but you could spell this with some kind of you know other
这可以是一个组合子，我想在 J 中，一个双元钩（dyadic hook）可能做类似的事情，这就像是等价物，就像它说一个二元和一个一元函数的两个并置，或者将一元应用到其中一个上，应用到右边那个，然后照原样取左参数，然后像这样应用二元操作——这可能是可能的，尽管在 J 中他们选择（你知道的）让双元和一元钩意味着与它们原本不同的含义，就像钩在 APL 中不存在一样，我们使用 B1 组合子和 B 组合子，但你可以用某种你知道的其他
combinator here which would then even make it i think even more but then that's once again it's like you know here's psi it's it's that's the question is how much do you expect people to know and in my opinion these composition patterns like once it's like entering the matrix like once you once you start to see them like you can't you can't un they're everywhere it's all that's that's that's that would be exiting the matrix entering the matrix means that you're would mean that you're like unaware of the reality of nature exiting the matrix would be the thing that you're looking for but anyways i just got nerd owned nerd owned boom uh but you should put that that last one back so that we can show the uh show the user the the listener the dear listener um yeah if they're if they're still listening yeah if they're still listening this is uh i don't i don't know how many
组合子来拼写这个，那甚至会使它，我想更……但随后，那又是一次，就像，你知道，这里是 psi，这就是问题所在，你期望人们了解多少，在我看来，这些组合模式——一旦它就像进入母体一样，一旦你，一旦你开始看到它们，你就不能，你无法不看到它们，它们无处不在，这就是，那就是——那将是离开母体。进入母体意味着你，会对自然界的现实一无所知，离开母体才是你要找的东西。不过无论如何，我刚刚被书呆子式碾压了，被书呆子式碾压了，砰。呃，但是你应该把最后一个放回去，这样我们就可以向，向用户展示——向听众，亲爱的听众展示——呃，是的，如果他们，如果他们还在听的话。是的，如果他们还在听的话，这，呃，我不知道还有多少
more of these bqn episodes we can do before we start like they are the most fun episodes for you and i to do but i can't tell they're probably the worst to listen to yeah it's got it yeah they are if they are let us know we'll uh hey we have some fun interviews coming up. Don't worry. It's not all Connor and Price discovering BQM. Maybe we got to do a YouTube stream. I think that's going to be the solution here is that we got to have a YouTube channel. Well, I wasn't even sure what... ESP the YouTube channel. Yeah, I wasn't even sure what we were potentially...
这样的 BQN 节目我们可以做，在我们开始觉得——它们对你和我来说是最有趣的节目，但我看不出来，它们可能是最难听的节目。是的，懂了，是的，它们是，如果是的话，让我们知道，我们会，呃，嘿，我们有一些有趣的采访要来。别担心。这不全是康纳和布赖斯探索 BQN。也许我们得搞一个 YouTube 频道。我想那将是这里的解决方案，我们得搞一个 YouTube 频道。好吧，我甚至不确定……ESP YouTube 频道。是的，我甚至不确定我们潜在的……
Because last time we were talking about how we were gonna delve into thrust partition but i feel like we got to organize that with uh allison and we'll just do like yeah we'll take half day off to yeah allison is uh is one of the engineers on my team who is the the lead for uh thrust and cub you know what do you think of the on the matrix note are you worried or concerned or excited about the new movie? I actually am not that big a fan of the Matrix. I just saw an opportunity to nerd on you and nerd on you. Like, I know that there's a new movie. I don't really care about it that much.
因为上次我们在谈论我们将如何深入探讨 thrust partition，但我觉得我们必须和艾莉森（Allison）一起组织一下，我们只需像，是的，我们会请半天假去，艾莉森是，是我团队中的工程师之一，她是 thrust 和 cub 的负责人，你知道的，关于进入母体那点，对于新电影，你是担心、担忧还是兴奋？其实我对黑客帝国不是那么大粉丝。我只是看到一个可以对你进行书呆子式碾压的机会，然后就对你进行了书呆子式碾压。就像，我知道有部新电影。我其实并不是很在意。
Fair enough, fair enough. We'll let the listener react to that i'm sure a few people have been insulted anything else we should say while we're uh before we close out this episode i feel like this ended up being like an hour so i don't know if we're gonna have to cut this into two parts or i should just leave this all as one i'm taking a look we're looking at an hour and three minutes but i mean but like 20 of those minutes was us talking about our dating life that you're gonna have to cut out yep we've been we've been bryce and i we joke about starting a second not podcast but like series on this podcast where fridays we release technical content and you
也罢，也罢。我们会让听众对那个做出反应，我确信有几个人已经被侮辱了。在我们结束这一集之前，我们还应该说点别的吗？我觉得这最终持续了一个小时左右，所以我不知道我们是得把它剪成两部分，还是我应该把它全部留作一集。我看了一下，我们看的是一个小时零三分分钟，但我的意思是，但像其中的 20 分钟是我们谈论我们的约会生活，你必须把它剪掉。是的，我们一直在，布赖斯和我，我们开玩笑说要在本播客中开启第二个不是播客的系列，比如星期五我们发布技术内容，而你
know mondays we release uh our dating podcast but uh that's probably not gonna happen so yeah probably we're gonna cut that out as well maybe we'll see we're gonna get ourselves in so much trouble connor why is that it's our podcast we talk about what we want yes but there are sometimes consequences for the things that we choose to say thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你知道，星期一我们发布我们的约会播客，但呃，那大概不会发生，所以，是的，大概我们也会把它剪掉，也许我们会看看。我们自己会惹上大麻烦的，康纳，为什么这么说？这是我们的播客，我们想谈什么就谈什么。是的，但是我们选择说的话有时是有后果的。感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。